Speaker 1: Let's try Matthew from
Jersey. Matthew, please save us.
Speaker 5: Hello?
Speaker 1: Oh, my God.
You're not running a lathe
in the background, are you?
Speaker 5: And do you need any.
Do you need me to do something?
Speaker 1: Yes, please. Run a lathe. No,
I'm kidding. Go ahead. What's. What's
going on? What's on your mind today?
Speaker 5: Well, one thing, of course,
that I've been thinking about is now obviously
this has changed a little bit with last night's
primaries because a lot of left wing people
late one there was some early John Fetterman,
Charles Booker. I think there was a few in Oregon.
But what I was going to say, thinking about
beforehand was. You had similar to how you said my
whole, you know, Trump's momentum that was so big
and it went then it starts to go
away. Thank goodness Hawthorn's gone.
And so it made me think, you know, I think
so many of what made me think of Bernie,
who I like a lot by, you know, his name is big
number one spokesman Nina Turner, the symbol of
the left wing movement. She ran. She ran. She
she ran for Congress the first time. Almost,
almost one close call then. So she runs the
second time, gets obliterated and makes me
think is the Bernie factor also losing its luster?
And furthermore, since Bernie was never president
then, was it ever really there to begin with?
Speaker 1: That's a fair question. I mean,
I've said before, as a Bernie
supporter, I recognize that
the perception of Bernie's level of support
was pretty significantly overstated. If you
spent a lot of time on Twitter and Reddit
relative to the Democratic Party at large. I
don't know that I would say that that Bernie's
Bernie's losing its luster. I mean, I think
Bernie's not been a major factor in the last year,
I think is what I think. Matthew, I have to ask,
what is all that noise in the background?
Speaker 5:
You know, I don't I don't hear any noise.
Speaker 1: It sounds like either a didgeridoo
or a lawnmower. I'm going to answer the rest
of the question offline, just just so we don't
subject our audience to the torture there. I think
what's going on is that some of these races, Nina
Turner, I think, is a good example. And I know
people get really mad when I make this analysis.
The electorate in that district, I forget what
number of district in Ohio is just not as left
as maybe it seemed from the national enthusiasm
behind Nina Turner. It's not an insult, it's
not an attack. It's just the recognition that the
people that voted didn't really seem to be buying
the Nina Turner ideology, what she was selling.
And we just have to recognize it kind of goes back
to the earlier question of it is a progressive
more likely to win? Well, where in what district
and what state and when, when? And so I think that
there's no one answer to that question, but it's
less about Bernie's momentum or whatever. It's you
know, there are there are places where the voters
that maybe they're wrong, maybe they're
ignorant, but they prefer something different
than Bernie. Nina Turner And we all have to
just kind of recognize that and meet people
where they are, at least initially. And
then then you see what changes you can make